hey youtubers it's Charlie this is gonna
be my fear The Walking Dead episode 5
video and I think we may have just found
where they've been keeping all the
walkers on the show the interesting
thing about this episode is that the
title is cobalt that was actually the
working title for the entire show when
it was still in the pilot phase before
they decided to name it fear the walking
dead they just called it cobalt so let's
dig into the buffet just careful for
spoilers from the episode if you haven't
seen it yet I'm gonna start with top 5
moments and new round of the giveaway
starts now all you have to do to enter
is be a subscriber and leave a comment
on this video so here we go meet the
world's greatest salesman you are a
buyer because I am a closer this century
seems like a really interesting new
character I think he's going to survive
- season 2 he just seems like he got to
media of a storyline - for them to just
kill him off next week before the
episode the actors that plays Ophelia
was actually gonna introduce him on her
Twitter so I think he's gonna turn into
one of the other main characters
eventually he does seem a little bit
sinister but remember the most evil
people that we've seen on the show or
the military they're actually worse than
the walkers we haven't really met a
governor type character someone that's
just like straight up evil like
classically insane evil but the
lieutenant seemed pretty bad they left
him in that building whenever they ran
out the dude took off to San Diego so
who knows if we're gonna see the
lieutenant again he might show up in the
finale I'm kind of hoping he does
because he would make a spectacular bad
guy David they were giving him so much
setup I could do whatever I want I have
all the guns is that not a governor in
training if we've ever seen one on to
number four Madison finds out about the
party that Daniel is holding for that
soldier in the basement the twist is is
that she's not horrified by it now on
the same coin she's not like dawn from
the hospital and Walking Dead Season 5
she's not batshit crazy or anything like
that but yeah she's kind of dark that to
me is just laying groundwork for a
really awesome character in season 2
those kinds of characters like Daryl for
instance someone who doesn't really like
violence but isn't afraid to do violence
is actually way more fun speed which on
to number 3 Travis vs. the gun so this
actually seemed like it was set up to
give us some Travis backstory into why
he hates gun so much like maybe he comes
from a past like Daniel like a history
of violence that he's trying to escape
from maybe not escape in the sense that
Daniel literally had to escape from a
war but
it seems like Travis was very
comfortable when he was nuzzling up
against that gun like Navy he's done it
before or maybe he came from a violent
childhood either way he's seemed like
the only adult main character that just
couldn't go through with it couldn't
resort to violence he's like I can't do
it I'm not doing this that'll probably
change by the finale but right now it
actually seems like some of these female
characters and Daniel are stronger than
Travis they're not like Shane hardcore
it's not like you know you get a cut on
your leg and it's like all right well we
got to kill him now speaking of putting
people down on to number two Liza versus
Griselda it was like they were saving
the best result a moment for last they
gave her that awesome speech where she's
hallucinating the devil where she's like
I've seen the devil's face and I see it
in you now you could take that a couple
different ways the metaphor is you know
Liza is the devil like it's her face
that she's talking about or she's
talking about the faces of the returned
dead the walkers like that's the devil
but she had to give Liza props she did
not hesitate to use the cattle gun and
now we have a main character with the
important information like the most
important information they always come
back after they die and they need to
suffer traumatic brain injury to go down
completely
I don't recall the military guys
explaining that to Travis I mean they
took the walkers down with headshots so
they know but I can't remember if they
explicitly explained it that way to
Travis like you have to shoot them in
the head or they won't go down but
finally on to my number one WTF moment
Daniel tortures the soldier and finds
out what the word cobalt means the
military is going to bug out at 9
o'clock tomorrow morning and it's just
going to be them they're leaving
everyone else behind but as part of that
they have a protocol for the quote
unquote humane termination of everyone
at the quarantine zone if you're
confused about why Daniel went to the
arena I think that he's going to release
all those walkers to either create a
diversion or just as an act of vengeance
against the military either way the dam
is going to burst and that is where all
the walkers have been hiding on the show
everyone's been wondering hey this is
the Walking Dead where all the walkers
that well that's it right there that's
where they're at the soldier explained
that they'd actually been keeping all
those people there is like a refugee
shelter and one of them started to turn
and they all just went super fast so
because he couldn't tell who had turned
and
had not turned he just locked the
building up chained the doors and ran
let me know in the comments though do
you guys think there's gonna be a bigger
moment in the finale next week than
those walkers just spilling out of that
giant arena it's like The Game of
Thrones episode this year hardhome when
all the whites just pour over the cliff
face just a river of undead bodies so if
you have a friend that is not watching
fear The Walking Dead next week is the
time to get them to start watching and
just to be clear next week is the finale
then the week after that is going to be
Walking Dead Season six Episode one now
there's only been six episodes so
there's still so many questions that
they've given us that they haven't
answered yet like why does Travis hate
gun so much is Daniel gonna go off the
deep end when he finds that his wife is
dead and is he going to find out that
Liza is the one that actually killed her
even though she had to I don't know that
that's gonna make a difference there's
price still gonna be some huge drama
between them
Daniel kind of seems like he's on the
fence he's one of those characters that
understands violence knows that he has
to use it to get what he needs to
survive but his family seems like his
weak point like when he finds out
something happens to his wife because it
could push him over the edge he you go
completely crazy I'm not expecting any
of the other main characters like the
the family members including Daniel's
family to die aside from his wife
obviously died in this episode I think
that they'll make it to season two I
think most of the larger characters that
will see die our military characters and
make no mistake a whole bunch of people
in that quarantine zone are probably
gonna die you know even even though the
guy has the key and he's gonna get out
with Nick they'll definitely escape but
there's probably a whole bunch of people
in there that will totally turn into
walkers it's gonna be like a deja vu
moment with that arena that the soldier
was talking about one of them started to
turn and then they just spread like
wildfire I know it's been a slow start
it's taken a couple weeks but I do feel
like fear The Walking Dead has great
potential like some of these carriages I
feel like the development on some of
these characters is way better than the
development on some of the main show
characters originally like it took them
a while to turn Carol into an awesome
character Madison on the other hand is
getting there way way faster and I feel
like Travis will get there too like once
he hits the tipping point he'll pick a
gun up and he'll start killing people
again or killing walkers that is so
what's gonna happen is is because so
much is going on with Walking Dead now
I'm definitely gonna do a Q&A for that
tomorrow I've also got a game of Thrones
Q&A
so hopefully nothing really important
happens on Monday because I've already
got to videos to make if you guys need
to catch up on fear the walking dead I
add all the videos to like my Walking
Dead Master playlist so just go to my
youtube homepage and just scroll down
and look for the Walking Dead playlist
in case you guys didn't see it either I
just posted a game of Thrones bonus
video all about the northern houses in
the North remembers storyline you can
click here to learn all about that and
you can click here for all my other
Walking Dead videos thank you so much
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tomorrow